being in prison what it does to your
mental health
it has a devastating effect on it
it makes you feel weak
makes you feel sad it makes you feel
happy it makes you feel all different
type of emotions
and sometimes you can't escape those
emotions
it's a familiar story
shortly after being expelled from school
stefan fell into the wrong crowd
landing himself in prison
but despite being diagnosed with autism
and adhd his needs were never addressed
and his mental health started to
deteriorate there's violence there's
noise
this one with autism that's a that's a
very bad place to put them noise lies
everything's going on at once
so it's like every day you're having a
sensory overload but to them it's a sign
of disobedience bad behavior
because of
because of the lack of understanding
and eventually he began to self-harm
i got scars on my arm i called him
choices between life and death he isn't
alone
in 2020 for every 1 000 prisoners there
were
691 incidents of self-harm
and a recent report into the criminal
justice system
found there are failings at every stage
there has been too little progress over
the last
10 years there's been a particular
failure to pass information between
different parts of the system
and we're seeing an acute shortage of
mental health hospital beds and very
long waits for community services as
well donna and her family know this all
too well
her brother tommy took his own life
whilst in prison
but she says before this the warning
signs were loud and clear he was cutting
his face
he tried to set fire to his cell
um
and he had his mental health
deteriorated very significantly
following his move to segregation
and he was given absolutely no access to
any mental health support during those
three days that he was in segregation on
the lead up to his death the inspectors
are calling for major improvements
across the system
starting with a common definition of
mental ill health to ensure that all
those charged are able to understand and
participate in the criminal justice
process
shaman freeman powell sky news